[Music]  while it looks like tree bark there's  more here than meets the eye  this is Madagascar's mossy leaf-tailed  gecko there are a few animals in the  world that exhibit such incredible  camouflage as a mossy leaf-tailed gecko  growing up to 6 inches in length their  bodies are lined with small flaps of  skin that help scatter their shadows  making their outline nearly invisible to  predators endemic to madagascar these  geckos spend their lives on the trunks  and branches of dense rainforest fauna  nocturnal in nature they use their  elliptical shape pupils to hunt for  insects and small invertebrates in the  dead of night in spite of their  formidable camouflage the mossy leaf  tail geckos future is threatened due to  deforestation and increasing demand in  the pet trade this is the mossy  leaf-tailed gecko  [Music]  you